-♪ Search Party, Search Party ♪
-Alright, welcome to an at-home
version of "Search Party"
with the Roots!
-Whoo!
-We have Gabrielle Union
and Questlove
playing against Tariq Trotter
and James Poyser.
Since we're playing at home,
I know it's gonna work
a little differently.
First, I'll read the start
of a quarantine-related
Internet search,
and then you'll take turns
guessing what the top answer is.
If you get it right,
you win the round.
If not, the other team
gets a chance to steal.
Make sense?
-Makes sense.
-Alright.
Gabrielle, the first search
is for you.
Question 1. "Will I regret
eating an entire blank?"
-No.
[ Laughter ]
-No is a good answer, but --
-"Will I regret
eating an entire pizza?"
-You think that's
what the Internet thinks?
-I do believe.
-Good answer.
-That is good. That is
the number-2 answer, however,
not the number-1 answer.
So the other team, Tariq and
James, get a chance to steal.
-James, what do you think?
I think, you know -- Man --
-Bag of chips?
-A bag of chips? No, never mind.
I'll just act like
I don't have a partner.
[ Laughter ]
-No, I think cake.
I think cake probably.
-[ Imitates buzzer ]
-[ Laughs ]
-No one said cake.
Who's going to eat entire cake?
What's wrong with you?
-Yo!
-An entire cake?
-It's real out here, man.
-When you hear it,
you'll be like, "Ah, of course."
-What?
-Alright, guys,
no points for this round.
The number-1 answer is...
pint of ice cream.
-Oh! Of course!
-Of course.
-Cake is too much!
Pizza, not enough!
We're going to do this. Tariq,
let's start this next search --
It starts with you.
Question 2, "Is it a bad idea
to blank by myself?"
[ Laughter ]
There are kids watching,
but, you know,
it is a late-night show.
-I'm-a be a little more
politically correct.
You know, I'm going to go with
the second thing I thought of
and say drink.
-We looked at the search things,
and you're close.
It's -- Number 2 is get drunk.
"Is it a bad idea
to get drunk by myself?"
That's Number 2.
That means Quest...
-Yes.
-...and Gabrielle can steal
and get the points for this one.
-Okay, I have a real-life
situation in this.
-Okay.
-Can I say it?
-Yeah.
-I trust you.
-I've been yelled at
for watching a series
or starting a series without
other people in the house,
so, "Is it bad that I'm --"
-Binge, like, all by yourself?
-Binge, binge-TV-watch.
That's a good answer,
apparently. Go with that.
-Tariq is not -- is being mean.
He's on the opposite team.
-No, I'm not talking about you.
-Yeah, but he's trying to
have you give you a bad answer.
-Because I can only think
of naughty things,
I'm going to go
with that very safe answer
that's not going to
get me in trouble.
-Wait, who --
So, this is the Internet?
-Yeah.
People are searching for --
They have quarantine questions,
and you think
someone typed in --
Most people typed in,
"Is it a bad idea
to watch a show by myself?"
-No. Okay.
-Oh, of course.
Yes. That makes perfect sense.
-No, it does not make
perfect sense.
I didn't realize.
-"Is it a bad idea to give
myself a haircut by myself?"
-Yes.
-That is the number-1 answer!
-For real?! Oh, my God!
Are you kidding me?!
-Number 2 was get drunk.
Number 3 was quarantine.
-Yeah, I was going
to say quarantine.
Dang.
-Quest, the next search
is for you.
"What's the best way
to order blank online?"
-I think buying clothes online
is the hardest thing.
So --
-Trust me, it is.
It really is.
-Wait, are you helping me,
Jimmy, or you --
-No, I'm just saying, like,
I buy a lot of clothes.
And during these times,
it's been really --
you know, way more difficult.
-No, that's not even
in the top three. No.
-James, what do you think?
-Liquor. Easy.
-Oh. No, no, no. No.
I think it may be
more broad strokes, you know.
You can get, you know,
under this same category,
liquor and pizza falls.
You know what I'm saying?
As do, I don't know,
paper towels.
This is all stuff that you order
that's considered what?
You go to the blank store
and get all of this stuff.
-Are you playing your own game?
-[ Laughs ]
-Can I just say --
I can say the answer I think?
-Yeah. What's the answer?
-Groceries!
-Groceries?
-No, not groceries?
-That was my second guess.
-Number-2 answer is groceries.
-Aah!
-No one's getting points -- No
one's getting points for this.
Number 2 was groceries.
Number 3 was alcohol.
Number 1, "What is the best way
to order toilet paper online?"
-Ah!
-James.
-Okay, here we go.
-Next search is for you.
No help from Tariq,
which is the way
the game's been going so far.
[ Both laugh ]
Question 4.
"Is it safe
to eat blank right now?"
-"Is it safe to eat takeout?"
-Takeout...
is the number-1 answer!
You got it! Oh, my gosh.
-Yes.
-Takeout is the top answer,
takeout/delivery. "Is it safe
to eat takeout/delivery?"
Number 2 is meat.
Number 3 is bleach.
-[ Laughs ]
-This is real, man.
This is real.
Gabrielle, the final search
is for you.
And this round
is worth 1,000 points,
so it's still anyone's game.
"How many days in a row
can I wear blank?"
[ Laughter ]
-Okay, underwear.
-Easy.
-Underwear.
I mean --
-Good answer.
-Underwear is
the number-2 answer,
which means...
-What?!
-...Tariq and James
have a chance to steal!
-James.
-For 1,000 points,
"How many days in a row
can I wear blank?"
-Is it a mask? Is it gloves?
-Oh, a mask.
Or --
-Gloves. It might be gloves.
-Might be gloves.
Is it sweatpants? T-shirts?
-No, no.
-Mask and gloves.
Mask and gloves.
-No, one or the other.
-Mask and gloves?
-Got to choose.
-In that case,
toilet paper or disinfectant?
Which one is it?
-Which one, 'Riq?
-Which one is it?
-Like, I'm going to put it --
I'm going to get --
Your dad is a pastor,
so I'm going to go ahead --
I'm-a let you
make the final decision.
[ Indistinct conversation
in distance ]
-Masks.
-Masks are not even on the list.
-Oh!
-Damn!
-People are living
at home every day.
"How many days in a row
can I wear blank?"
-Probably jeans.
-Pajamas.
-It's back to us?
-Yep, for 1,000 points.
-I'd say pajamas, but --
-Pajamas or jeans or --
-Pajamas are...
number 3.
-Socks?
-Pajamas, underwear.
No one's got
the number-1 answer.
Tariq and James for the win.
Please just say it.
"How many days in a row
can I wear..."
-Sweats.
-The winner right there!
Number 1, sweatpants!
-Hey, we won!
-Pastor's son James.
-What did you win?
What do we win?
-A new car!
-Some new sweats, hopefully.
-You get Questlove's
home cellphone number.
[ Laughter ]
Personal one.
Personal one, the one
he actually picks up.
I love you guys.
Thank you for playing.
-Love you, too, bud.
-My thanks to Gabrielle Union,
Questlove, Tariq Trotter,
James Poyser.
You guys are the best.
I miss you.
We'll be right back with more
"Tonight Show," everybody.